well we have official word from the
Pentagon that indeed there has been a
test of a missile that would have
violated the intermediate-range nuclear
forces treaty that treaty is now expired
and the USA has conducted a test of a
missile that would have violated it
here's what we heard from the Pentagon
the Department of Defense conducted a
flight test of a conventionally
configured ground Floyd's cruise missile
of the u.s. West Coast Sunday the test
missile exited its ground mobile
launcher and accurately impacted his
target after more than 500 kilometers of
flight now the test was conducted on San
Nicolas island off the coast of
California
we understand furthermore that the test
was announced on August 2nd the very day
that the INF treaty expired now the
official reason for the United States
withdrawing from the INF treaty was that
they accused Russia of violating that
agreement now Russia has said they did
not and denies violating this agreement
we've also heard from Russian President
Vladimir Putin who emphasized that
Russia won't be the first to boost its
military if the USA were not to escalate
following the withdrawal of the treaty
this is what the Russian president said
if we receive verified information that
the US has finished developing and
started producing these systems Russia
will be forced to begin its own
full-scale development of similar
missiles so even after the United States
withdrew from the INF treaty we did not
see an escalation from Russia however
the United States has proceeded to test
this missile that would have violated
the treaty now it's important to
remember that the INF treaty was signed
in 1987 and it was a key moment in the
scaling down and de-escalation and
eventual end of the Cold War however
that INF treaty that banned nuclear and
missiles of a certain length is no
longer in effect now Russia has
repeatedly reached out to the United
States for dialogue around this issue
but so far the conversation hasn't
seemed to start
you